good afternoon
thank you so much for being here today
i'm casey darling a senior here this
year
i'm studying political economy and i'm
from fort collins colorado
and i'm very happy to be here at
hillsdale for my final year
it is my pleasure today to introduce
nick lloyd he is a senior lecturer
in defense studies at king's college
london
based at the joint services command and
staff college in shrevenum wilshire
dr lloyd earned his phd from the
university
of birmingham and subsequently taught at
the royal air force college in cranwell
lincolnshire he is the author of three
books
lou's 1915 the amritsar massacre
the untold story of one fateful day
and hundred days the end of the great
war
which was recently named one of mclean's
best reads of 2014
and a must read by the new york post
he is currently writing a new history of
the third battle of epra
in addition to a biography of sir
michael o'dwyer
the lieutenant governor of the punjab
during the first world war
please help me in welcoming dr nick
lloyd
hello good afternoon i am the last
englishman you will hear at this event
so
it's really wonderful to be here at
hillsdale and i would like to thank
dr jeffrey dr casper dr ahn
for inviting me here today and to the
center for constructive alternatives for
hosting this event
it is rare indeed that one gets to share
the stage with such esteemed fellow
historians
and before such a distinguished audience
i have been asked to give a talk on how
the great war ended
and i think it is entirely appropriate
in this centenary year
to remember how this awful conflict came
to its conclusion
indeed this is a subject very close to
my heart
from an early age i've known about the
war contrary to most people's
understanding my view
was not conditioned by the great battles
of the somme or verdon or passchendaele
as we talked about yesterday but of how
it ended
or perhaps i should say how it had never
ended especially for my late grandmother
gladys mary cottrell
who never forgave germany and the german
people for the loss of her elder brother
thomas
who died in september 1918 barely six
weeks before the armistice
you can see tom there the last
photograph
was taken of him in 1918 and of course
you may not be able to read it but the
picture on the right is the telegram
that they received from the war office
the worst
telegram in the world tom's story became
in a sense the inspiration and guide
behind the book and it was born out of a
desire to find out more about how he
died
and what it meant tom cottrell was just
19 years old
when he was killed in action just
outside the small village of guzo corps
southeast of arras in northern france he
had been conscripted a year earlier
and served with his battalion the 15th
royal warwickshire regiment
in italy before returning to france in
the spring of 1918.
tom's loss always haunted my family on
the morning of 27th of september his
mother florence woke up with a searing
pain in her head
this is according to family legend at
that very moment tom's battalion was
taking part in the battle of the canal
du noir
one of a number of climatic battles on
the hindenburg line
when she had recovered she had a dark
sense of foreboding that something had
happened
and then on 23rd of october 19 days
before the armistice
the telegram arrived from the war office
confirming that private george
thomas cottrell had been killed in
action
tom was killed in the last great
campaign of the first world war
what has become known as the hundred
days or the advance to victory
it refers to the decisive last phase of
the war on the western front
between the massive tank attack at amion
on 8th of august
when the allied advance really got going
and the armistice on 11th of november
when it came to an
end this is actually a total of 95 days
but historians have always called it 100
days not because they couldn't do maths
but really to make a conscious
connection to the 100 days against
napoleon
in 1815.
one of these things that drew me to this
period and certainly drew my publishers
to this period
was how poorly these battles have been
remembered
indeed it's been a favorite lament of
generations of british historians to
bemoan
the lack of appreciation of what really
happened in the final months of the
great war
particularly the leading role that the
british expeditionary force took in it
as long ago as 1978 the historian john
terrain complained
that the final campaign of 1918 is
virtually an unknown story
and this remains the case today after
all who has heard of the battle of amion
or the battle of the sombra
the battle of saint miguel or the mers
are gone
they have it seems been lost to history
my book hundred days was an attempt
to allow a new generation to rediscover
them
and is on sale after this talk
i just want to throw that one out there
it will be i think very interesting to
see what place the 100 days has in the
official commemorations of the great war
that we are
now about to go into in january 2013 the
president of the western front
association in the uk
professor peter simkins wrote to the
times on the best way to honour the dead
and called upon the government to
include the battle of amion in its
commemorations which had hitherto not
been included
he claimed to accord amion a victory the
same status as the first day on the
psalm
a defeat would be a significant step in
the right direction
the current official program is as
bizarre as marking the centenary of the
second world war
by commemorating the fall of france but
not d-day
in a strange coincidence all the main
protagonists had their own reasons for
forgetting the hundred days
in britain the memory of the war as lord
egremont talked yesterday
would always become associated with the
solomon passchendaele
the great attritional battles of 1617
and almost no amount of revisionist
history has been able to shift that
for us the truth of the war was mud
blood futility
and an awful lot of poetry victory in
1918 wasn't really part of that myth
in germany the last battles remain
under-researched and little-known
understandable i think given the old
stab in the back myth that claimed the
german army had not really been defeated
in 1918
but been betrayed by traitors jews slavs
at bolsheviks at home therefore there
was really nothing to be learned from
the final phases of the war because the
german army didn't really lose it
if anyone should have remembered the
hundred days should been you guys
the arrival of u.s troops in strength
for the summer of 1918
played a key role in the defeat of the
german army something that is i think
too often underappreciated by
eurocentric historians
yet america was not to remember her role
too fondly as she lapsed into
isolationism and retreat after 1918
and condemned president wilson for
dragging them into someone else's war
a related point you sometimes hear
and i've certainly had this is that to
accord the 100 days some kind of victory
heroic status
is misleading between mid-july and
november 1918
the allies sustained upwards of seven
hundred thousand casualties
um german sources are at least eight
hundred thousand although
uh we cannot know for sure given such
heavy losses how is it possible to call
this period
a string of victories
yet when i wrote this book i think it
led me to challenge many of these
assumptions
firstly i believe that 100 days is
really important and it's only by
examining this period in detail will we
understand how the war came to an end
the germans may have lost the war by
july when their final offensive petered
out
but the allies had not won it and the
ferocity of the fighting was testament
to how far the war had left to run the
book begins with what in hindsight
emerges as the real turning point of the
war
the franco-american counter-attack on
the man on 18th of july
that rested the initiative away from the
german army
i then chart the development of the
grand allied counterattack that took
place
over the coming months telling the story
of the momentous events that ended the
war
the stunning success at amion in august
the advance to the hindenburg line
the climactic battles at the end of
september
and finally the pursuit and retreat
throughout october and into
november the men responsible
for these operations were on the screen
these are the chief donkeys if you will
on the left the french commander in
chief philippe petter
dower savior of the french army after
the mutinies of 1917
trying to shepherd his shattered army
home field marshal sir douglas hague
head of the british expeditionary force
ever optimistic and bullish and at the
head of an army reaching its peak of
effectiveness
yet undermined at home by a prime
minister david lloyd george
who loathed him on the right you have
general
john black jack pershing
commander-in-chief of the american
expeditionary force
inexperienced and aggressive who found
european-style
trench tactics too cautious and thought
breakthrough operations led by american
riflemen
would win the war and finally in the
center the small trap
the allied generalissimo marshall
ferdinand fosh
a committed catholic who had lost his
only son in 1914
yet was still devoted to the offensive
after all these years
although fosh was their nominal superior
he really had more of a coordinating
eisenhower type role chiving everyone
along and trying to get them to work
together
something that was not always easy with
such headstrong commanders
nevertheless in 1918 they work well
together
following the counter-attack on the marn
fosh wants to maintain
pressure on the german army so he
orchestrates what he calls a series of
movements
intended to seize key objectives and
keep the initiative
although he was hopeful of great results
he had little idea
that they were on the cusp of the
greatest series of offenses
of the war
this is a map of the western front as
you can see the shaded areas are the
areas that the germans had
you know occupied during this spring
offensive when they
bring all their troops back from russia
and try and win the war in the west
by july their offensives are ground to a
halt and then
the culminating point changes and the
allies mount their
offensives i think a number of themes
emerge from
the book the way in which the allies
were able to fight in those last months
the importance of courage and
determination of the highest order right
to the very end
and the nature of german defeat and the
destruction of her army
turning first to the allies and how they
fought i think there was no doubt
that by the summer of 1918 they had
created an effective and particularly
brutal way of fighting that proved its
worth time and again
someone asked yesterday about what did
they learn over the four years
well hopefully in this period you can
very much see the degree to which they
learn
losses may have been substantial they
always were
but they were more manageable than ever
before and moreover by 1918
attacks usually met with progress
sometimes significant progress
the americans met with less success but
this was primarily due to a lack of
artillery a lack of air power
and logistical constraints
the hundred days witnesses some
outstanding examples of allied tactical
superiority
particularly the attack at amion which
kicks off fosh's series of offensives
a series of movements on 8th of august
this was a crushing blow to german hopes
of holding on to their gains of the
spring
some australian troops behaving in a
very undisciplined manner
on a tank covered by a thick fog
and using the latest artillery
techniques that negated the need for his
preliminary
artillery bombardment surprise had
finally returned to the western front
spearheaded by the elite canadian on
australian corps
with 500 tanks the allied attack broke
through the line east of amion and
almost destroyed the german second army
in all german losses were as high as 27
000
with the loss of 400 guns and all in a
single day
it is no wonder that general ludendorff
the german commander would subsequently
call it
the black day of the german army in the
great war
it was after amion that 100 days really
gets going
the german army begins to fall back
while the allies follow them as closely
as possible
in september at san miguel the us first
army goes into action
the first time that a unified american
force had gone into battle
on the western front
there is no doubt the german army morale
begins to
i think plummet quite alarmingly at this
period the hopes of victory which had
been raised
to a fever pitch at the beginning of
1918 now produced a crushing sense of
desperation and fatigue
right across the army all the high
command could do was pull
back units into their last main
defensive position the hindenburg line
and hope to hold on if that position
fell
the road would be open all the way to
berlin
this is an example of a german postal
sensor
which illustrates the declining morale
i think was very useful for giving a
sense of what the german armies really
begins to go through
yet however bad german morale becomes
much depends on how the
how long the allies could maintain their
advance and keep the germans on the run
logistics were crucial to this story and
the difficulties of moving armies at
speed during this period has in my
opinion
never been fully appreciated if the
hundred days was anything
it was a triumph of engineering
in their path the allies found wrecked
villages lethal booby traps
destroyed wells torn up railways and
felled bridges
as the french commander eugene debonai
wrote the terrain they crossed was full
of shell holes
all the houses destroyed ruins nothing
but ruins
the destruction they encountered was
methodical even the fruit trees were cut
down however through a combination of
hard work
good leadership and honed military skill
the allies were able to keep going
for example between august and november
the royal engineers built over 330 stock
spanner rolled steel bridges
approximately twice as many as they had
erected in the preceding four years of
war
it was this kind of improvisation that
was vital to victory in 1918
gradually as the german retreat gathers
momentum fosh
begins planning for a major set-piece
operation to get through the hindenburg
line
when he had planned his series of
movements in july he had no thought
that they would lead to such decisive
results but the speed of the german
retreat now called
for a new plan
by mid-september fosh finalizes a
four-step offensive with operations
being conducted right across the front
but all working towards one objective to
attack key positions
and stretch german reserves to breaking
points
as you i'm not sure whether you can make
out the blue arrows but it shows the
uh what fosh is trying to do is
effectively trying to pinch out
the german bulge into northern france
and that was about
as close as a flank as you could get on
the western front certainly in the south
on 26th of september the french and
americans would go forward in the mers
argonne north of verdun
to try and sever german rail lines and
seize the city of sedan
the following day the british and
canadians would push onto the canal due
north west to kombre
on 28th of september the belgians the
british and the french
would mount an offensive in flanders and
finally on 29th of september
the british fourth army would assault
the hindenburg line along the crucial
saint quentin canal
because of the logistical strains that
such a massive series of operations
would demand
it was necessary to mount them on
successive days one after the other
fosh's strategy was i think in many ways
quite brilliant
he has finally moved away from the vain
and costly effort to reach deep into an
enemy's position
the longed for breakthrough that never
came and
understand understood that in the
context of 1918 the width of the attack
was critical
he wanted to attack at different parts
of the front at the same time
trying to overwhelm enemy defenses and
prevent reserves from being able to
intervene
because german reserves cannot be in
four places
at the same time in late september this
has spectacular results
the americans would kick off this
massive series of offenses
driving through the battered woodland of
the mers argon an environment that
somehow people have
said is reminiscent of the wilderness
campaign of 1864 you can see something
of it in the photograph
that i've just put up the story of the
mirza ghana i imagine will be familiar
to at least some of you
general pershing was faced with the
brutal reality of modern combat
against a skilled opponent and despite
outnumbering their enemy many times over
the attack quickly bogged down the
ground was awful
as one veteran claire grover of 79th
division later recalled
in the confusion of the attack barbed
wire across no man's land continuous
shell holes forests machine gun fire
companies were broken up into little
groups over the next three days his
regiment suffered 1200
killed wounded or missing in his sector
alone he counted over 113 machine guns
in fixed positions
supported by at least half as many
moveable weapons
simply nothing had prepared from the the
intensity of firepower on the western
front
pershing was so incensed at the failure
to progress that he demanded
increased efforts sacking commanders
wherever he could and ordering renewed
attacks
the problem was that was that without
the sophisticated logistical support
an overwhelming artillery fire available
to the british and french
u.s operations would struggle to
suppress enemy defenses
was it then a failure just another one
of those horrendous
western front offenses that went nowhere
not really the fact that the americans
were there
in such numbers there were over a
million men in france now
was proof enough of u.s commitment and
will to victory
as crown prince ruprecht a german army
group commander noted grimly
the americans are multiplying in a way
we never dreamt of
elsewhere pressure on the german army
was now becoming intolerable
further north the british and canadians
had managed to penetrate the hindenburg
line on 27th of september
when my great uncle was killed and the
key bridge was secured at recaval on the
saint quentin canal two days later
which sent shock waves right across the
front
because obviously now that you have a
bridge you can get tanks across
for the german army the failure to hold
on to the hindenburg line was
devastating
defeat was now inevitable thousands of
deserters were stalking behind the lines
while the number of reliable troops and
experienced ncos was dwindling
to dangerous levels had the war gone on
for much longer
who knows what would have happened eric
ludendorff
the german first quarter master general
would now make a fateful decision
there he is not a man you'd like to meet
in a dark alleyway
it's a terrible thing to say but all
german commanders of the first world war
look like this
it was on 28th of september the third
day that ludendorff realizes the game is
over
it's six o'clock that evening as news
comes in of a massive attack in flanders
fosh that foshad orchestrated he goes to
the chief of the general staff paul von
hindenburg
and tells him that they need to do
something immediately
they need to sue for peace
why had ludendorff made such a decision
how could this hardened prussian warlord
suddenly give in especially if his army
is still fighting very very hard
and especially when the german army is
everywhere on occupied territory
the controversy over this decision has
never abated
it's sometimes been suggested that
ludendorff had some kind of nervous
breakdown and collapsed in his office
foaming at the mouth
although this was denied there does seem
to be something in it
in august 1918 staff at the german high
command
was so worried at ludendorff's mood
swings and erratic behavior
that they arranged for an eminent german
psychiatrist a dr hockheimer
to visit the general you can imagine the
scene
as far as i know i'm the only person to
have used the letters that dr hockheimer
writes to his wife
about this period and they offer a
really interesting insight into the
psychological state
of general ludendorff when hockheimer
meets ludendorff he finds him overworked
and exhausted he wanted the general to
lessen his frantic daily schedule
so he had the most beautiful flowers
brought into ludendorff's office
which he hoped would lighten his mood
quite amazingly ludendorff seems to have
responded well to this
by mid-september aides were noting a
transformation in its general demeanor
which had been pro which had been
improved by less work in the afternoon
and more sleep
which dr hockheimer carefully observed
this is some quotes that you can find in
dr hockheim's diaries
my patient is doing better each day the
calming effect of my words has made me
quite happy
hockheimer gives ludendorff a book to
read called rhapsodies of joy
by paul steinmuller it's not a title
i've particular
familiarity with but ludendorff
apparently finds this hard to understand
and incomprehensible
however the worsening news at the front
means that ludendorff's mood
deteriorates
significantly in late september on 28th
of september which is the key day
hockheimer writes one line in his diary
it storms
at ludendorff from all sides
whether he collapsed or not is
impossible to say okay meth or not
but there is no doubt that ludendorff
lost his nerve at a critical moment
and thus sparking off the process of
peace negotiations that would bring the
war to an end
from this point onwards the long torture
story of the armistice begins
the german government sends a note to
president wilson on 3rd of october
asking for peace negotiations based on
the 14 points
they did this unsurprisingly to try and
split the alliance hoping wilson would
conclude a more favorable piece
than they would have received from the
french or the british alone
but this was not to be after various
correspondence with wilson trying to
ascertain whether this is the real deal
and whether
it is an honest approach he finally
agrees to grant an armistice
should a number of terms be conducted be
fulfilled such as the evacuation of
occupied territory
and the cessation of submarine warfare
the key question was whether the allies
could trust the german government
on 21st of october washington sends its
final note to berlin
making it clear that it would not deal
with any german government
unless it was democratic and had the
military authorities under control
so why does germany agree to the
armistice on 11th of november
if its armies were still in the field
well it's quite simple
they were holding on it is true but with
every passing day the situation gets
progressively worse
and brings a final inevitable collapse
closer
events at the front i think prove how
wise and indeed inevitable this decision
was
the small but significant action at mont
we on first of november
shows what lay in store for the german
army had it continued to resist
now i've been told that people from
michigan don't like canadians
and if that is true then you might want
to look away now
the hill of mont we commanded the town
of valancion and by the end of october a
number of british attacks had come to
nothing against strong german units
heavily dug in it was then that sir
arthur curry
and the canadian corps moved up to the
line and agreed to capture it
but curry says okay if you want me to do
this i need one thing from you i need
every single gun you can get your hand
on
and they need every single round of
ammunition
a report on the operation concludes
owing to the fact that the german army
was approaching a defeat on a grand
scale
and that there was much peace talk in
the air it was decided that all
restrictions concerning the economical
use of supporting arms
were now out of place and it was
therefore the proper time to neglect
economy
six brigades of field artillery 104
heavy guns
supported by nine batteries of heavy
machine guns were brought up to the
front
and for anyone that doesn't know that is
an awful lot of firepower
because of the layout of the ground it
is possible to deploy a great deal of
artillery forward
and enable a combination of not only
frontal artillery fire
but also oblique enthalate and
incredibly reverse fire
just one canadian brigade went up the
hill on first november
supported by what historians have judged
to be one of the most intensive fire
plans of the war
during the attack seven tons of high
explosive
were fired every minute on a front of
less than two miles
some people have suggested that it's
almost the most concentrated use of
firepower before the atomic bomb
it is little wonder that the american
historian scott stevenson wrote
that to be a german defender in the path
of a major allied attack later in the
war
was to experience the horrors of dante's
inferno
one of curry's staff officers wrote this
it's a description of
basically the carnage that he finds on
that hill
in total the germans suffered 800 dead
the canadians had suffered just 60
fatalities
an astonishingly light figure given the
strength of the enemy defenses
and the limited number of attackers it's
worth bearing in mind that the germans
are heavily dug in
and that the germans outnumber the
canadians three to one yet the canadians
basically inflict
ten times as many casualties that they
receive
monthly was the face of battle in 1918.
the nightmare of the psalm had been well
and truly banished
this was about as effective as war on
the western front was ever going to get
if anyone tells you the allies did not
learn
anything from the war simply say mont
hui
for germany it's the end of the road
crown prince ruprecht notes sadly
that what we must therefore do if we are
to avoid a military catastrophe
which will destroy our whole future as a
nation is to make haste and approach our
enemies and especially england
with peace offers which both can be
accepted and in view of the temper of
the english people
must be accepted ruprecht knew the war
was lost
the only question was whether they could
save enough of the army for the greater
battle they could see looming
the fight against the bolsheviks at home
and the struggle for the german soul
if the army was destroyed and the allies
marched into the fatherland then more
than a war would have been lost
there was an urgent need to ward off
something that was in his words
far worse
ludendorff was finally sacked on 26th of
october to be replaced by general
wilheim groener
not perhaps the most recognizable german
general but a solid choice
he was not a firebrand prussian but
someone who had spent the war running
germany's railway network
and who was familiar with the political
situation in berlin
if anyone could arrange a strategic
retreat it would be groener
and now the drama moves
to the kaiser
the kaiser's last day is 9th of november
and it is really the final moments of
imperial germany as it crumbles under
pressure from all sides
that day he has been in deep discussions
with hindenburg and their generals at
his villa
in the belgian city of mums arguing over
the state of the war and whether the
army would hold firm
until now the kaiser had steadfastly
refused to offer any political
concessions
and still believe that the army was
loyal to him if he went
he said repeatedly there would be total
anarchy in germany
it was up to groner to dispel what he
called the fantasy world the kaiser and
his aides lived in
he believed that the army's morale was
breaking and the loyalty to the tizer
kaiser was tottering german soldiers
would never agree to mount an operation
within their homeland against the
socialists
so something had to give in the end
groener tells the kaiser and this must
have taken some courage
that the army no longer supports his
majesty although
although they would march back to
germany peacefully and orderly they
would not follow his orders
this was the final words that the kaiser
tells groener
um bitter very very
bitter within hours the kaiser was
heading for the dutch border
aware that revolution is stalking the
country and afraid that mutinous troops
are actually marching on spa
well here's the man general groener a
quote is basically
his reaction to what he did his
explanation
um groener stand was a remarkably
courageous thing to do
and nationalists did not like take long
to accuse him of treachery and defeatism
nevertheless groener seems to add a much
deeper objective awareness of how
perilous germany's situation was now
how fragile the army had become and how
it needed peace at any price
four days earlier groener had received a
letter from a divisional commander at
the front
who was an old friend major general
loffler commander of 192nd division
it told a story of exhaustion and
despair that was shocking
my dear groener lofla began i am writing
to you because from the general
headquarters
insight into the troops doesn't
penetrate deeply enough to measure
combat strength by its actual value
the strength of the troops is running
out you know me well enough to know that
i am not a pessimist
my division hasn't had a single day of
rest since the beginning of may
for weeks and months on end only biv wax
have been possible
there's been no talk of proper
sanitizing de-lacing and the like for
just as long
from what i have been able to gather it
has been the same with every other
division
yet we've done our part every day brings
proof of that
the moment of overturning is however no
doubt approaching
it is no longer a matter of weeks
eventually there comes a time when every
action fails due to fatigue
it is into the state that we are now
entering
authorised by the kaiser the german
armistice delegation met fosh on 8th of
november
signing an armistice three days later
and bringing the great war
to an end
the story of 100 days is as i chronicle
in the book
an epic tale of slaughter and sacrifice
heroism and tragedy
i tried to show what it was like to
experience the twilight of the western
front
the shattering bombardments the storm of
machine gun fire
the sight of hundreds of dead and
wounded the exhaustion of endless
marches
the glow of burning villages the
comradeship and fear
should the war have continued could the
allies have kept going
why did they not enter germany and force
a total unconditional surrender like
1945.
these questions remain difficult to
answer and riven with controversy
there is no doubt that the allies would
have found it enormously difficult to
maintain their advance into november and
december
the spearhead of the bef its fourth army
was now 50 miles from its rail heads by
the armistice
and only kept supplied via a handful of
narrow thinly cobbled roads many units
were lacking reinforcements
increasingly unhappy at being asked to
keep going and most importantly
approaching the limit of their physical
capability
and as we know nobody wants to die when
a war is about to end
there can be no definitive answer to
what would have happened had the war
gone on
this is counter factual terrain but a
complete collapse of german resistance
in 1918 is probably unlikely
large sections of the army would
probably have escaped their pursuers and
slipped across the rhine
particularly given the difficulty the
allies were having in keeping up
which became harder with every mile they
covered every village they liberated
and every river they crossed more than
likely a new offensive
would have been necessary in early
spring of 1919 to finish off the germans
which would have been militarily
possible but would have put both the
british and french governments
under intense domestic pressure to stop
the war
nevertheless in hindsight i suspect the
allies should have kept going whatever
the cost
something that general pershing was
definitely advocating
only through the systematic breaking up
of germany
and the reversal of the unification of
1871 could france's long-term security
be assured
yet the partial victory of 1918 which
left germany weakened and constrained
but not crushed
meant that there was always a
possibility she would rise again
but war weariness combined with woodrow
wilson's opposition to too much
interference in germany
meant that there would be no radical
reshaping of the fatherland
and no military occupation except for
the rhineland
thus began the long and sad progress of
two decades of missed opportunities
and appeasement when the allies
collectively let slip the priceless
advantage they had gained
after the second battle of the man in
july 1918.
while some celebrated on 11th of
november particularly on the streets of
paris and london
for the vast majority of allied soldiers
the news was retrieved with relief
and happiness but alongside an
overwhelming sense of loss
and despair and grief
that's tom's grave
10 million soldiers had died including
my great uncle
another 20 million had been wound or
scarred forever
large parts of europe were blaze four
empires had collapsed into a sea of
conflicting nationalities and ethnic
groups
vying for power and influence the
armistice may have brought the fighting
in france to an end
but in one form or another the war would
go on
thank you very much
thank you we will now take questions
thank you dr lloyd for that insightful
lecture at directly following our q
a session there will be book signing of
dr lloyd's book hundred days
the floor is now open for questions
uh so on november 11th
were the what was the distribution of
troops i mean were the lines
pretty much uh as they had been the
previous
months and or was there some sort of a
retreating by the germans uh
i think i can probably go back in slides
actually
if we go back to the first map that's
that's basically the blue line don't
don't look at the shaded bits but the
blue line is basically the western front
between
end of 14 to beginning of 18 it stays
pretty much like that
by the end of the wall if you can
imagine from the bottom it just simply
goes straight up so you've
you've got to the point where most of
belgium is now liberated and you are
closing in on the german border so
you've crossed that so that
that line is well and truly god
but the the myth does persist that the
line doesn't actually move
and there was a television program in
the uk bird song
it's a terrible book and it's a terrible
film at the end of the war
um the trap that gets buried he's on the
somme
and um the whole point of it is that the
line doesn't move and it's a complete
myth actually
the line you know by the time they get
tonight you know the last phase of 1918
they are
they are getting closer and closer to
the german border and the old
battlefields of the psalm and
passchendaele have been left far behind
the problem is though that um getting
all that kit and
oil and ammunition through those
battlefields is very very difficult
hi i just have a question about your
research process um you mentioned that
you were looking at some letters that no
one else had probably looked at yet
um i was wondering what drew you to
those and also um
if they were hard to access i think you
probably answered your own question the
fact that no one had looked at them
before was
ideal really so much historical research
is
you know you are based on you're looking
at well-worn sources that
annoyingly people have already looked at
so you you try and uh look for things
that haven't been seen before
and that's really what i i managed to
find a copy of these letters and uh i
thought this is great stuff particularly
the
the kind of vivid descriptions that
hockheimer describes
uh ludendorff i thought this was
wonderful so really as a historian you
you do try and look at what everyone
else has looked at perhaps read it in a
different way
but you are always searching for the um
if you like the holy grail of a source
that's completely pristine and new and
radically transforms your opinion of a
certain topic
it doesn't really exist very often but
it's it's the search that all historians
go on i think
are there any statistics on the
incidence
of suicide among the combatants
i think that's a very interesting
question um
it is not one i have an answer for um in
terms of
those people who wear self-inflicted
wounds that kind of thing um you do get
that
um in terms of suicide i'm not sure i
really know about that question
um do you have a particular
i mean i mean personally i find the
western front depressing enough as it is
without
going searching for suicide
was poison gas uh pretty well
over as far as an offensive weapon at
that time
um it is used it is used quite
extensively in 1918
and not so much as an offensive weapon
the germans use lots of mustard gas as a
defensive weapon
because you can fire that stuff and
basically you can fire it at map
references and you can basically block
out
whole map references with because this
stuff mustard gas is terrible because it
stays in the ground
so it can remain infected for for weeks
on end so you can't move troops through
it because
you get infected so what the germans do
as well as using artillery and barbed
wire they use
they fire thousands and thousands of
shells of mustard gas
as they retreat so it means that your
the allies are moving forward in a
chemical environment which slows them
down even more
the british do use mustard gas as an
offensive weapon it's proved
particularly
effective at counter battery fire
earlier in the war you use gas in terms
of cloud attacks you get loads of big
cylinders in the front line and
you know try and get the gas to go over
the trenches and that never really works
because you're at the
mercy of the weather and the right wind
direction so what they do is they begin
to use more and more amounts of gas
firing it on german batteries because
even if they don't hit the german
battery and knock it out
by physical means the fact that you've
got a cloud of gas means that it's much
more difficult to operate those guns
so 1918 is a chemical battlefield you're
absolutely right
can you hear me all right i suppose so
yeah my father
my father was in world war ii i mean
world war one
and uh he was in the royal air force and
i noticed that you haven't
mentioned and most many of the speakers
in this whole session have not spoken
much
about aircraft and warfare in the air
the things he mentioned most to me which
this is a long time ago you know
he said when they would move in france
they would go from one farmer's field to
another and then as the
as the troops moved on they would have
to get another farmer's field you know
to fly from
in what really impressed him though i
think
a lot of people here would recognize it
that one thing he
enjoyed the most or remembers the most
is whenever they moved from one field
to another the salvation army was always
there
before they got there and he was of
course has made him a lifelong
supporter of the salvation army but why
is it
that we haven't had much mention of air
power
there's very good mentions in the book
so
um no you're absolutely right air power
is a key element
um i think i don't mention it because
there's so much
else to get through um air power is
critical to allied success at the end of
the war and it actually becomes very
very sophisticated what they're doing
with their power and they're trying to
integrate it much more effectively with
ground troops
by 1918 the royal air force is
photographing the entire british sector
of the western front twice a day
every day that's over 80 miles up front
you can imagine what kind of
intelligence picture that gives it's
almost unprecedented
they're helping the artillery they're
even dropping supplies they're dropping
ammunition they're dropping water
on the front troops particularly given
the supply problems they have in 100
days
they're also beginning to experiment
with putting wireless sets into tanks
so that tanks can communicate with air
power to try and help tanks knock out
enemy anti-tank batteries so you can
really see air power becomes
um you know it becomes into its own very
much in
the later stages of 1918 and plays a key
role and i think just some of the things
they're trying to do with air power in
1918 is really revolutionary and
forward-looking um given that you know
the right
the wright brothers only flew in 1903.
by 1918 you have the birth of modern 3d
warfare
you know and that that's the end point
of the learning curve it's how to
you don't necessarily you need to
basically invent the kit first
inventing air power inventing bomb sites
inventing
weaponry inventing better engines and
you have to then
work out how you use it and then you
have to integrate it with tanks
with artillery with their power so i
think when you look at it from that
perspective airplane
is absolutely critical and is a key
element of what we call the learning
curve
just two quick questions um did germany
have an air force
you never hear anything about that they
did but it was shut down
they got shot down they did have an air
force it's very good obviously you may
have heard of baronville manfred von
richthoven
he is not around at this time he's been
shot down but um one of the problems the
germans have
by 1918 is they're running out of fuel
so
they are they're not able to mount the
kind of sorties that they every so often
they can get a group of aircraft and
mount a
sort of small range salty but they don't
have the numbers of aircraft that the
allies have
they're not able to contest control of
the air on any kind of operational level
and by the hundred days they're having
to
it's in some ways like second world war
they're having to draft in trainee
pilots
all the main all their all the aces have
been killed all the
all the big names have been killed by
this point um
and they don't have the the ki they have
some excellent aircraft but there's not
that many of them
and the allies are are just blowing them
out of the sky
one one last point was there a point
where
trench warfare ended and then became
offensive
there wasn't trench warfare through the
whole war was there
no no not really i mean basically you
have the trench deadlock is broken in
march 1918
with the german spring offensive that's
when germany basically gambles
they say right we've we've taken russia
out the wall we're going to bring
everyone now to the west to the final
battle and we're going to win the war
so once the germans break out of that
trench deadlock in 1918
using some pretty innovative tactics
from that moment onward
trench warfare as we know it is over
and from that moment is semi-mobile
yes sir could you tell us something
about the
eastern front between the brits
and the germans sizes of the events
and where they took place etc
uh you mean the the eastern front
between russia the
russian empire and germany
well there were brits in the east
i mean we're talking about holy land
area
oh you mean the eastern front is in the
middle east sorry vega pardon
um by 1918 the ottoman empire is on its
last legs
and you have a series of climactic
battles where allenby's um
british mediterranean expeditionary
forces it's called
goes up all the way through palestine i
think all the way to aleppo and destroys
the ottoman empire they also destroy it
in mesopotamia so they're basically
the the ottoman empire is confined
basically to to what would be
sort of modern-day turkey and they
suffer the same problems that the
germans have
um lack of offices lack of complete
collapse in morale
and so on so forth um this really
happens at the same time as the 100 days
it's
it happens in september you have the
great battle of megiddo which is where
the turkish army is
basically routed and then cavalry
columns follow follow them all the way
up the coast
oh you mentioned the possibility of a
bolshevik revolution in berlin
would you comment on how realistic that
was
and also the western powers these the
victorious western powers demanded the
german uh renunciation of the treaty of
breslautovsk
i've often wondered why we sort of
played
uh we basically played into the hands if
you will of the new soviet government
and perhaps
didn't uh maybe not giving germany
anything but perhaps
uh insisted on some concessions from
them
um i think i think it's a difficult one
because that whole area is in chaos so
you're
you know you don't have the power the
allies don't have the power to actually
have some kind of order in that region
um so they're trying to make the best of
it and they're trying to
clearly make sure that germany does not
secure an empire in the east
now clearly whether the soviets were a
worse danger
certainly some people in the british war
cabinet but believed so
winston churchill for example is very
keen on destroying bolshevism
at this point um but again you have a
choice what what do we do we we've got
the
we've got the pressure on germany so
that's really on the only level we have
we barely have any contact with
bolshevik russia
um the likelihood of a revolution in
1919 or 1918
in in germany you have a revolution in
munich
in bavaria certain people were very
worried that this could happen
if you read um any of adolf hitler's
works he's always talking about the
the chaos that inflicted on germany in
1918 1919
but of course you have a lot of
returning soldiers who join what they
call frick or free corps
units that go and take on the bolsheviks
in berlin so
there clearly is a possibility i'm not
really sure how close they came to
revolution
i suspect it was never that likely but
there clearly is a significant threat
there
in the last 100 days to what extent do
general montgomery and general patton
get to use their
techniques on tank warfare that they
take into world war
ii um i think in patton
obviously he has his little brief um
experience of combat in the mirza ghan
um and then goes on to sort of talk a
lot more about tank warfare clearly
tanks aren't going to be very useful in
the mizargan because the terrain is so
bad
so i think it's an example of where you
don't fight you don't fight
in the mirza going don't fight in the
woods you know i think sun tzu tells
that
um as for montgomery i think
montgomery's interesting because
montgomery
um if you if you look at the british
army in the second world war from 1942
onwards
they basically do first world war
battles
massive artillery support a structured
battle so we're going to go this far and
no
no further we're going to you know the
british army is not capable of doing the
sophisticated maneuver warfare that the
germans are so good at
so basically what we're going to do is
just take this line and no further
so if you like the montgomery is a is a
product of the first world war and he's
involved in 100 days as a
i think he's a colonel in one of the
divisions
and this for them is is how you do it
you do limited attacks using
overwhelming artillery fire
and you don't ask too much of the men
because frankly
they're not up to it this will be our
final question
yes um hello it was um mentioned earlier
about the um
potential state prior to the revolution
of the eastern front between the um
germans and bolsheviks and could you
tell a bit more about
the state of the war leading up to the
end at that point
well obviously you have um the russians
basically give up at
the back end of 16. there are some
offences in 17 but
when you have a revolutionist in the
spring and then finally in october the
bolshevik revolution they really give up
um the army begins to go home
the germans then advance deeper and
deeper into russia to compel some kind
of surrender
and so by early 1918 several weeks
before the spring offensive in the
in the west they compel the treaty of
breslistovsk
on russia the soviet union which is a
very
horrendous piece most of western russia
now comes under german
control or at least you have a
theoretical control
by this point the austrian hungarian
empire is on its last legs as well
they are on the point of collapse huge
problems internally
so the whole i mean we tend to think of
wars coming to an end as being
kind of clean and crisp or at least we
used to this whole that central and
eastern europe is in complete chaos
um but for germany it becomes
increasingly clear that
the eastern empire is a key war aim so
even though they bring an awful lot of
the best troops back in the west for
that final blow
they still have a million men in the
east trying to secure
ukrainian wheat fields and bases on the
black sea and so on so forth
um and that is the sort of stasis that
fluid situation where
um germany has effectively won in the
east
it has won the war in the east it is
able to destroy poland and destroy
lithuania and the baltic states but
cannot cannot simply cannot win in the
west
you could argue actually what they
should have done in the spring of 1918
is simply
put everyone in the west and they're not
attacked
and and then had some kind of
negotiation because in the east they had
won
thank you dr lloyd
thanks very much
thank you again dr lloyd uh we will be
having the reception right after and
students as a reminder please use the
stairway to the left
thank you